the land is here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you bill I'm good Rick are you
all right so what do you know as you
currently know it with me right now bill
I mean I guess about as much as you know
where we're trying to gather information
now is Ohio state sort of enters this
investigation phase we have no idea how
long it's going to take I think we all
know the the the central question here
is whether or not Urban knew about Zack
Smith in 2015 and and if he knew if he
did if he went through the proper
protocol I heard you talking before you
brought me on and you mentioned that the
title nine language and Urban's contract
it seems fairly clear in his contract
that if these allegations from Courtney
Smith said Urban Meyer knew and that he
didn't report that he would be in
violation of his contract so that's kind
of what we're waiting on now to see
whether or not Ohio State can find that
out of us in the course of its
investigation in the urban so who's
doing the investigating bill I'm
assuming it's Ohio State's athletic
department and then its attorneys it's
an in-house investigation as far as we
know we have not heard anything about
any any outside resources being pulled
in to help just yet not to say it can't
happen but at the moment it seems like
it's being handled in-house by Ohio
State the University athletic department
and then its legal team all right and
and is there a deadline spurring action
here and in terms of the playing season
that's right around the corner
well they start camp on Friday so I
guess they had to get something figured
out and the short term which is why they
put urban on paid administrative leave
yesterday certainly there's a few weeks
before they play a game they don't play
until September first
I think you'd want some some clarity by
then but I honestly think you'd want
some clarity it's funny to use urban
sort of benchmark but he always says you
know two weeks before the season you got
to be ready to go you got to know who's
playing and I would assume you'd want to
know who's coaching so they'd probably
have three weeks I would say to get
things in order before they really start
rather worrying about where they go in
terms of the football season bill Landis
if cleveland.com joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show all right so now let's
get into what you believe because again
that's all we get to go on right now and
the three questions are is it easy is it
believable
based on what the text that we saw from
from Brett McMurphy
on this subject that Urban's wife never
told him what was going on in the text
exchange between her and Courtney Smith
well that's a difficult thing because
there certainly as far as I've read the
report Retin barfi and from what I have
done digging up myself there is no
straight line to urban that says he's
for a fact know about this I'm not
saying I disagree with Courtney Smith
into saying we don't have hard evidence
of that just yet but to your point it is
very difficult to believe that if
Shelley Meyer knew about this that she
did not tell her husband and urban I
think Ten media days it's interesting
talking about something completely
unrelated I don't even know why he was
asked but he was asked specifically
about his relationship with Shelley and
and how she sort of helps him run things
and he made a joke about her like
talking about when they run the
quarterback and went not to but he got
serious and he talked about how they
share everything how she's his greatest
confidant their partners I believe for
29 years remarried for 29 years it
doesn't seem like they keep anything
from each other from the way he
described it so maybe in the end that
could be a damning quote from him
because with what he said about his wife
it's very hard to believe that she would
not have told him this if she knew it
and it's it again it's just so when you
talk again about another man's wife or
another woman's husband when you talk
about spouses it's a it just puts things
on a completely different plane when
you're when you're talking about a job
and and who gets to stay in it or not so
it seems to me bill you can tell me if
I'm wrong in this investigation that
Ohio State is doing these the ultimate
witness here is gonna be Urban Meyer's
wife to ask her point-blank did you tell
him or not and ask him point-blank did
your wife tell you or not and that's
that's gonna be whether or not
Urban Meyer stays his head football
coach at Ohio State am I missing
something on that front no no I I think
that was what we know at the moment and
it puts and it's not not to paint urban
in the light of being victimized here in
any way but it does put him in a tough
spot that if that is the case and they
can prove that she didn't tell him and
they want to keep him as head coach that
he has to go up in front of Americans
like
put the blame on his wife I I just I
that was that's a difficult road to go
down so much that that's part of what
leads me to believe that even if they
can prove that urban didn't know this
the TR of it all I think it's still lead
to Ohio State making a coaching change
or urban deciding this step aside or
something all something that ends with
him not being the head coach even if it
is found it found out that he did not
know about this and I asked this
question with respect in the utmost
ginger way what's going on with the
wrestling team does that add any extra I
guess sensitivity to getting this right
if you will know oh yeah hundred yeah
high state is dealing with a whole other
monster with with the rampant reports of
sexual abuse by a former team doctor and
wrestlers and other athletes so they
can't have two things blowing up on
their face on the PR front so yeah they
have to get both of them right obviously
and they're investigating the doctor and
they say they're investigating Herbet
but obviously when you have two things
going on once it puts much more pressure
on you to make sure you get the both
right and handle it the right way bill
land is here on the Rich Eisen show and
in that press conference in the Big Ten
media day I mean bill a colleague of
yours asked point-blank - Urban Meyer if
his relationship with Earl Bruce and the
Bruce family had anything to do with the
way he was viewing Zach Smith on this on
his coaching staff and I'm wondering if
you could lend any thoughts and
perspective on that yeah I think it
absolutely did I'm sure on some level
whatever Urban knew I there's another
layer to this relationship that goes
beyond employer and employee urban
Urban's greatest mentor in coaching as
Earl Bruce urban I don't think has ever
made a move in his career without
consulting Earl Bruce or was always
around the program until he passed away
a few months ago it's a very important
person or Durbin's life probably second
only turbines father in terms of the
influence that he's had on on urban and
you're talking about that guy's grandson
so I think urban certainly felt indebted
to Earl
- I don't know if protect is the right
word but but to make sure things are
done right by his family and it's
possible that that clouded his judgment
he did admit that that the relationship
doesn't extend to that area but he also
said that zachsmith was hired because
one he's a good coach he played as a
walk-on for her but at Bowling Green so
maybe you ever would disagree with that
but but I think it's pretty obvious
that's that the relationship was a
little different than the typical head
coach assistant coaches so then let me
ask you this bill because again i came
across Urban's path a handful of times
at the draft you know we had a little
bit of fun or he was putting me a little
bit on ice cuz he knows I'm a Michigan
grad and and and then we actually worked
together on the air and in the interim
all my colleagues who knew him at ESP
are like he's a he's a warm guy he's a
good guy like you would actually like
him and I'm like I I'd love to meet him
and then I worked with him on that one
Friday night in Chicago when Ohio State
broke the record for most players
drafted in the first three rounds of a
draft and he was just he was a billion
and he was happy and he hands me his
number saying call calls showing ever
you want and then he came on the show
Michigan Ohio State week and and and you
know so I've got a chance to see who he
is and what is it believable though is
it believable based on you knowing him
and everybody who knows him that he
would somehow hear this from his wife
and protect Zach Smith because he
doesn't want to hurt girl Bruce that and
and this is now blowing up in his face
right now is because that is essentially
what is the storyline that is being
implied by all the reporting that's out
there right now bill yeah I guess I
don't want to say this as a way of
sounding accusatory but but I do think
there's plenty of evidence over the
years sort of about the the depth people
will stoop to to protect college
athletics their football programs their
personnel their family their friends I
would agree with you my interactions
with urban I've always been pleasant and
it's different probably for me than it
was for you I asked some questions he
gives answers but he's always asked for
my questions I've ever had any sort of
bad interaction with
but I think you can still have lapses in
judgment even if even if you come off as
generally a good person and a
well-rounded person I think everyone is
prone to lapses in judgment so if that's
what happened here I wouldn't be
surprised by that and we've seen other
places the things that people do
sometimes to protect you know big-time
college sports and then the last one for
you then bill the ultimate if this is
found out to be that urban because it
you know let's just get with the gray
area a gray area that they somehow still
don't determine whether urban knew
expressly although it's not terribly
believable that he didn't is that
something that they would want to part
ways with Urban Meyer over in Columbus
do you think bill yeah well I think
there are three and end results here one
he stayed as a head coach two they
outright fired him three they come to
some sort of financial agreement and
sort of walk away from it and and I'm
inclined to lean toward one of the two
that ends with him not being the coach I
don't know if we'll get out and write
fired I think that the language and his
contract is still working I'm not a
title nine expert it looks to me like he
possibly could have violated his
contractor I don't know that for a fact
but I think that murkiness combined with
the PR hit that comes with this how
difficult it'll be to run the program
moving forward if he does come back even
if he's down so enough done anything
wrong it just seems to me like it'd be
really difficult to move forward with
business as usual so so I'm inclined to
say that I don't think he'll be the head
coach in whatever form that takes
and Wow okay geez
so you think Urban Meyer is coached his
last down at Ohio State yeah I I do okay
and I'm not I'm not saying I think this
should be the case is my hunch my hunch
at the moment I think yes they'll
appreciate the time thank you well chat
soon that's bill Landers of Cleveland
calm the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience